what up guys welcome to the just of
pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to the pregame
[Music]
um before I start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that we are going to
be notified of my daily videos as you
guys already know if you have watched
two or more of my lives and you do not
subscribe we have beef okay beef people
a couple announcements before we start
the show the first is that we have two
clips channels the first is just pearly
clips and the second is Pearl daily we
have two different editors on those
accounts so make sure you go subscribe
to both you get two different types of
Clips
um the second is that we have four
membership tiers the first tier you get
to be a part of the live chat tonight so
if you all want to put anything in the
chat I'm sorry you gotta sign up for our
memberships it's only five dollars a
month month which is the price of a cup
of coffee the second tier you get to be
a part of our Discord and our behind the
scenes blog so the Discord we got a
little Community going uh we talk about
show topics sometimes I get ideas from
the Discord so make sure you sign up for
that also um behind the scenes Vlogs if
you guys want to see me freestyle
nobody believes me but I'm good at it so
you should get the second
um tier and you get to see it in my
behind the scenes Vlog the third tier
you get to connect with me on social
media and the fourth tier you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month
um a lot of people use this if they want
to grow on YouTube if you want to know
how to start a live show um sign up for
that because I have a lot of insights
that will make your life a lot easier
okay next Instagram they took away my
first Instagram so go follow my second
just pearly things one
um also on Tick Tock go follow my fifth
and sixth Tick Tock just probably things
dot five and just poorly things six I've
kept the one that I have um for almost
like a couple like two months now which
is big for me
um and I'm almost to 100K so go follow
that Tick Tock um if you guys want to
come on the show DM the pregame show And
subscribe to Wife School
if you're at 304 you're a modern woman
you want to be a wife sign up for a wife
School we're getting wives from Across
the Nation to teach us how to be wives
um
anyways um also thank you guys for um
some we have two super chats in the chat
already
um how's Cheryl um we're gonna read it
at the Super Chat break but
um thank you for the super chats to
start the show off strong
um all super chats are going towards a
camera
um in the back so it'll be like um a
camera towards the door we haven't
really had anyone get kicked off or
leave but in case anyone ever does then
we have a camera
um we also are trying to get a monopod
so when we do Street interviews um we
wanna it like balances the camera or
something I don't know blessing wants it
anyways um today we have a lovely panel
um so everyone why don't we go around
and say your name your age your
relationship status
um and a fun fact about yourself
starting here and then going around
okay hi I'm Ruth and I'm 40 and I
um
what's the other thing relationships say
as I'm single and fun fact oh gosh um
I'm a human rights activist
it's quite fun
so I'm Macy I'm 21 I'm single at the
minute and fun fact about me
um
I don't know maybe that I'm not from
London I'm from Newcastle
um but I just come here for uni maybe
that's a fun fact I don't know I'm not
that interesting
hi everyone my name is Laura and I am
42. I
I'm married
and a fun fact about me
um I like sports
hey my name is Georgette
go by G for sure I am 31 and a fun fact
about me is I'm dressing up as
Tinkerbell for a DJ party on Saturday at
the rocket project
hi my name is Robert
um you call me Ruby
um 28
single
um and a fun fact about me
I've got the world's most unique tongue
I'm 25. I'm single but I'm married to
the money
um fun fact about me you're married to
the money I am what does that mean man
money just get along so I don't know if
that was like uh okay
a fun fact about me um I'm at The Matrix
guys yep at The Matrix
I'm not involved in The Matrix oh okay
fine shout out Andrew Tate right shout
out my guy
um okay
um so today
um we are talking about abortion
um a little heavy topic today but
um so I have something that I'm going to
read so
214
256 abortions were performed in England
and Wales in 2022. the highest rate
since the abortion Act was introduced in
October of
1967. the standardized abortion rates
for residents is 18.6 abortions per a
thousand women abortion rates for women
under 18 has decreased from 15 or from
15 per thousand in 2011 to 6.4 per 1000
in 2021. 99 of abortions were funded by
NHS abortion rates are the highest among
women of I'm just curious guess what you
think what age is the highest I'm just
curious youngest I think so young up
2016 18 16 18. yeah I would say probably
18 maybe like 16 20. okay would you say
my mid-20s mid-20s you're the club 28 uh
22.
um as um the highest among women at the
age of 22 years old the largest increase
has been Between Women between the ages
of 30 and 34 years old
82 percent of abortions in the UK were
from women that were single 49 of those
women listed single with a partner as
their status
78
percent of the women noted their
ethnicity on the forms were white nine
percent were aged seven percent were
black and five percent were mixed 98 of
abortions in the UK were performed under
ground sea that the pregnancy has not
exceeded its 24th week and that the
continuance of the pregnancy would
involve risk greater than if the
pregnancy were terminated of injury to
the physical or mental health of the
pregnant woman 43 percent of women
undergoing abortions have had one or
more previous abortions
so question for the women are you
pro-life
Pro or pro-choice um just to clarify if
anyone doesn't know pro-life is when a
woman wouldn't have an abortion
um
oh wait oh sorry I'm reading this wrong
are you pro-life
I don't know pro-life or
pro-choice okay
Pro pro-life is when a woman wouldn't
have an abortion and doesn't want other
women to have either in pro-life
pro-choice woman pro-choice women is one
that wouldn't have abortions themselves
but want other women to have a choice a
pro a pro-choice pro-choice
I'm sorry someone sent this to me and
I'm like reading this wrong okay
basically like would you have an
abortion yourself and do you think it
should be legal is the question
so then go ahead
um
no and yes
yeah I'm pro-choice
um I think it should be legal and I
would have an abortion
um
I am pro-life and I think it should be
illegal
okay go ahead yes and yes okay
all right well you can't but
um but pro-life or pro-choice
I I think abortion is wrong okay so
pro-life yeah okay
um Pro Choice pro-choice
oh hi guys
um do you
um so today's topic is abortion and the
question is are you Pro what's your name
why don't you start with your name your
age and then are you pro-life or
pro-choice hi I'm Sunny I'm 25 and I'm
pro-choice
okay
okay
I'm taylor27 Taylor 27 um pro-choice
okay
um so blessing you want to play the
first video
like
experience with abortion and I don't
think we talk about this enough abortion
can be another word for Mercy some 16
year old's life has been irrevocably
changed because of the current
overturning of Roe v Wade and what its
implications are what it means to live
in a country that puts us in this
position and when you are a young woman
starting out your career your
reproductive Destiny matter is a great
deal well nowadays I couldn't take that
for granted I couldn't take that freedom
for granted the freedom of choice we
know that no two pregnancies are alike
and it follows that no two lives are
like that follows that no two
conceptions are alike so how can we have
a law how can we have a point of view on
this that says we must treat everything
the same when you allow for choice you
allow for flexibility which is what we
need in order to be human this is not a
moral conversation about abortion this
is a practical conversation about
women's rights and by the way human
rights because women's rights are human
rights and the freedom that we all need
to be able to to choose and build our
lives and have access to excellent
Health Care
my own personal experience with abortion
and I don't think we talk
okay so what did you guys think of that
video so you can start and then go
around
yeah um
yeah I think it's it's sad because she's
talking about the woman but she doesn't
make any mention about the the child
there's another life there's two lives
involved when we're talking about
abortion and one life chooses to end the
life of that innocent human being so I
think she's just totally ignoring the
other human being in the equation
um I agree with what you said I think
abortion should be legal I think it's
the woman's choice if she wants to have
an abortion or not
um
yeah
um
I I
take it from the Viewpoint of
the fact that
we are
not just to consider
um
just the individual I feel like
human life
um has
or the woman has a choice the bait The
Unborn doesn't have a choice
um so
you know that should be factored in
because that is another human life as
well so yeah
I think it's incredibly Brave of her
firstly to actually speak up and discuss
a subject on such a large World stage
that is so judged and like for her to do
that is a big step for the freedom of
speech around this topic and has
literally opened up the floor for this
topic I think considering the life of a
child it has to be encompassed of who is
actually raising that child you know the
child isn't just born and then becomes
its own soul and its own being it's
raised by as a byproduct of what the
parent currently is and the pattern and
the and the blueprint that the parent
has created and if you haven't yourself
done the work to enable yourself to be
the best possible parent of only
yourself and your inner child
to then be expected to raise another
child would actually be
a discredit to The Unborn being I think
like
to become a parent is to know that
you're ready
to raise another being and and consider
that actually you're passing on your
blueprint and if you still carry heavy
trauma then how can you raise another
being to its best possible
potential of Soul like
didn't I feel like people raised kids
with trauma all the time before yeah we
I think we all carry trauma to some
degree but if there's certain parts of
yourself that you haven't uh
eradicated or developed then like what
do you imprint that onto a child is that
quite a big thing okay go ahead yeah I
think age Gap
um I'm sorry age is really important
when deciding whether to get an abortion
or not and um
she was pretty old that woman so she
yeah
I don't really think she knows what it's
like to be in a position of someone
that's younger that might need to get an
abortion you know
um
I think depending on the age it's got a
very big part to play in it if you're 17
18 you need to get an abortion because
you know you're not financially unstable
to look after that child
then yeah I mean
you've got to have it but then again
that all comes down to you know your
decision to like have sex at that age
you know and um at that age I don't
think people should be prioritizing this
type of things you know at like 17. yeah
so you feel like it's kind of their own
fault
yeah I had a lot of friends in Primary
School
um and then they went to secondary
school and they got pregnant at 17. and
they kept like three of three of my
friends don't know them but yeah now
they all have children maybe even four
now I think okay
go ahead
um yeah so personally I think obviously
Let's Get the facts out there that
obviously it is murder right killing an
unborn child is still murder
um and obviously it is a separate person
like people think oh it's my child
um or it's my partner's child but
actually it's a separate person
um so yeah like it is a fact however we
have a free will and we have a choice no
matter what people say no matter what
they do we still have a choice no one
can change us not the God not devil we
can only change ourselves and we have
that Free Will so whatever we decide it
should be our choice okay
um what about you two
um
um I feel like like any challenge you
have to be ready for it if you're not
ready for it then
the results may go away is that you
can't even anticipate so I feel like the
circumstances that people are in before
they have a child should be taken into
account heavily when making such
decisions
um just the same kind of I don't think
you should bring a child into a
situation if they're going to be
resented
are unwanted
uh okay like just a quick question for
my own self has just been triggered is
like is it still classified as a human
being when it can't breathe on its own
um I mean I think that depends who you
ask yeah but like scientifically like if
you can't take your own breath are you
is it still classified
um well from the from the point of
fertilization when the sperm and the Egg
meat that's scientifically the beginning
of a new human being start so that's
when we all our lives all began and then
you just need time to grow into a more
you know adult version of yourself so
that is when life begins so is it still
classified even though you're not
dependent on your own 90 of um
scientists say that life begins at
conception so I'm curious
um okay so for the people that are
pro-life through one two three it's a
good mixed piano today when do you so
would you guys say that abortion should
be outlawed
completely
you would say yeah if you see me if you
say yes raise your hand
you think it should be outlawed
completely okay for the people that are
pro-choice
um when how long up to abortion like
should abortion be legal to tell
um up to birth up to six months up to
three months
or if you've a different number but
those are the three most common answers
I seem to get go ahead I mean of course
not up until the day that you're like
gonna give birth but
I think the day that it's at now was it
like 24 weeks or something yeah you guys
have six months also six months yeah I
think you know that the doctors and
people are saying six months is okay
then I think six months is okay okay I
mean personally I wouldn't have won you
know six months I would try and get as
done as early as possible but you know
six months then that's six months okay
at what point does it for like maybe
this is just my lack of knowledge but at
what point does it form
into
from a fetus to an actual being like
where is the form of the brain and like
where is the form of the heart like
where does that actual scientific
process like
uh transform
you know yeah universally right
um well I mean development is an ongoing
process right so actually the heart
starts beating at around 21 days
um and so a lot of women don't even know
they're pregnant then
um and the brain waves around six weeks
at eight weeks uh the baby actually has
um the 90 of the same organs that we
that we have as adults
so it's actually very surprising wait
say that again though eight weeks eight
weeks from fertilization so eight weeks
if you think about it most women find
out they're pregnant you know maybe they
miss their period and they find out five
six six weeks or so I don't even know
that so about eight eight weeks that
baby that all that embryo has
um yeah has 90 of the same organs that
you and I have at what point do we stop
like where's the transformation from
like embryo to fetus to baby I mean
these are just names so these are just
scientific terms so um the word fetus
just means little one in Latin and that
is from nine weeks we call it an embryo
it from the verse point it's called a
zygote then we call it an embryo up to
um eight weeks and then from nine weeks
onwards it's referred to as a fetus when
that when that child's born it's now a
baby then it becomes a toddler then it
becomes you know child teen major adult
these are just stages of development
they don't say whether we're you know
how valuable we are we don't say you
know that a teenager is more valuable
than a toddler simply because it's older
because it breathes for itself
well a toddler Breeze for itself doesn't
it yeah so I'm saying that a teenager is
not more valuable than it's an embryo
doesn't breathe for itself right it's
required someone else's breath to
survive is that when you think that life
conception like so at Birth
I'm kind of unpacking this as we go it's
just kind of interesting actually yeah
something that Cass said was like oh
hang on a second like
at what point is it actually still
dependent on like my breath to survive
like it's it's not its own is it a human
like it made me think like is it a human
being yet because it's not actually
being on its own it has to breathe
through me it requires everything from
when I say me I'm referring to the
female reproductive organs like it's not
being its own human at that point
it it has to break through me and that
got me really thinking about the actual
stages of this process because I'm just
thinking like that argument then you
could abort it like a couple days before
you give birth
which which I I don't know about you I
think we'd agree that's that's a little
late yeah you know I mean I would agree
with you yeah yeah and so
um yeah that's that if we go by the
breath argument um
but do you have any memories anyone in
the room of eight weeks old because
you're saying oh it weeks it's breathing
at three weeks it's breathing because
like I don't have any I don't have any
memories before the age of like five but
I hope they didn't care
[Laughter]
um what about like medical issues like
what's your opinion on that like if a
doctor said to like her mother like your
child's severely disabled it's not gonna
have a good quality of life like
they have a chance of dying before they
even reach a certain age like what's
your opinion on that
yeah I mean these these are real
challenges and real hard issues for any
parent to have to go go through
um but we I'd ask ask you you know let's
say I am pregnant and then I have have a
child and my child's disabled you know
my child is born and I find that my
child's disabled can I kill my child
once it's born well I mean obviously not
but why not why not if it's disabled
it's not going to have a good quality of
life is it well yeah but at that point
it's already been born I mean you're not
just gonna kill your child because once
it's been born it's disabled but
so what's the difference between that
born child and that unborn child well I
don't think abortion's murder so
that's my opinion on it so so then your
so your issue is not necessarily about
disability it's about
um choice
yeah so I was just saying like if they
said you know some children live until
like the one the two the three if
they're really really disabled and
they're going to be completely dependent
on the parent for the rest of their life
and the doctor's saying you know they're
going to be like really disabled would
you be would you still say to like a
mother like don't
get an abortion like carry on you know
bathe the child yeah I mean I don't
think that the disabled people are less
valuable or less Human Than able-bodied
People and whether I don't think they
should be killed born or unborn because
I think science tells us that they're
just as much human in the womb as they
are outside of the womb and I don't I
don't know if you know this but that's
like a common argument for you do you
know what Eugenics is yeah anyone
Eugenics no no okay it's basically like
trying to get like a more pure
population so a lot of people would
um like um a lot of people would do that
through like a
um through
what would they say so Planned
Parenthood in the U.S was started by a
racist and basically her whole plan was
to abort
they put abortion clinics in like the
black community there and then also in
low-income areas and then like disabled
like she felt like um you needed to get
like a more pure population So when you
say like should you abort disabled kids
it's kind of an argument for eugenics
but I mean I don't think you actually
think that but that's just um
yeah go ahead go ahead brief out of
interest if you yourself
um experienced something in life that
left you in a position where you were
unable to look after yourself and you
were unable to speak and be able to
communicate and able to be able-bodied
do you believe in I think I'm saying
this right is it euthanasia when you're
allowed to oh my God is that the correct
word see it's hard I don't like don't
think I believe in euthanasia but if I
couldn't move oh my God like what would
you do at that end so like as a
as a being that has like moved through
certain stages of like human uh
development for again once for a better
word would you yourself at the end of it
um would you still continue to desire to
be alive despite the fact that you had
no ability to continue experience in
life as you previously had like do you
believe in euthanasia at the opposite
end of life also or is it just that yeah
yeah or is it just that they're uh
beginning of the human creation I
personally believe that every human
being is made in the image of God so
that we all have um we're gifted with
with value and we have purpose and that
our reason for being is outside of our
ourselves our own there's a higher
purpose and so yeah personally I'm not
saying these things are easy but yeah I
would I would say I'd have to trust God
and you would like out of no choice of
your own
um continue like you wouldn't have a
choice but to be alive but if someone
close to you was in that situation and
you knew that there and they had
expressed verbally their decision or
like um their desire maybe is a better
word to want to be
um again like I'm gonna use the words
put down just because I don't know a
better phrase for it at the opposite end
of of the human creation is that
something like someone that was close to
you if they become um
severely uh disabled is it something
that you would respect as of their wish
because they was able to communicate it
and it was put on them as a Twist or is
that still regardless for you uh a
non-movor like no matter what
communication had received like even if
someone you love had had explained to
you really deeply that they didn't want
to be alive if they were within a
certain State and they chose verbally to
you confirmed that they did not want to
be alive and wanted to continue down the
euthanasian I don't know if that's the
plural for it process would is that
something that you would uh respect or
is that something that you would still
strongly disagree with to start funnily
enough um my grandmother when she was
alive she she used to express
um that she wished she could go to
Switzerland
yeah she said that like because she at
the end I mean she
it wasn't like a long long drawn out one
but she made comments like that but um
because then it would be her choice
right it wouldn't be well I think that's
the highest suicide I don't want to
misquote this but I'm pretty sure that's
like the highest suicide rate is among
the elderly and it's not always
um recorded because
um sometimes it's like I slipped and
thought you know yeah it just get
classified as old age right yeah yeah I
just think there's always hope whether I
think there's always hope you know there
is
I'm not saying these are not easy
situations but I think that there is
pain relief there is
um when when someone is in those
difficult situations it's an opportunity
for people around them to just show love
to show compassion to care for and yeah
I just I just believe in life and I
believe in hope so even if it who had a
verbal confirmation of tourists from her
I could never support you would never
support killing yeah I could never even
if it's for self for myself as in like
like for some person has said I would
like to die you know I would like to I
mean that's it's suicide isn't it it's
just yeah I'm a lot of people want to
die because of self pain like internal
pain but that can that could be a method
for that some people
some people can try things some people
don't get the right information and I
feel like that's where a lot of people
get lost I've worked in mental health
for a long time and that's all I heard I
want to die I want to die I want to die
but actually when you give them certain
methods and you help them process the
information and and their thoughts
um they actually change their mind so I
think it's you know someone that wants
to kill themselves not like they want to
actually kill themselves they either
want to change who they are or they want
to the pain or whatever they're going
through to stop
um yeah yeah so I'm curious
um so for the people that
are pro-choice if you guys saw new
information would would you ever change
your mind on that issue
like raise your hand if you would what
sort of information sorry I don't know
science like if we would then go against
abortion yeah like would is this an
issue you'd ever change your mind on so
you would never change your mind you
would never change your mind
you I think it's always like good to be
open to new information I don't think I
would ever really dismiss an information
Source before I had
witnessed it I think it's always good as
a human being to actually reassess your
beliefs otherwise you're just like
you're just standing by your ego
basically I think it's always good to
keep that in check okay what about you
two
um I feel like it's very situation based
so the science I don't know what new
science would uh change because the
science doesn't change like
the situation that brought the abortion
about so I feel like again yeah it's
very situational depends on like the
actual circumstances the mother is in
rather than what science actually has to
say about it so so no
but like again it would it would be hard
because you think there's certain
situations that like you would have a
hard time telling someone they couldn't
get an abortion in exactly okay I
understand what about you I don't think
any of us should say what someone else
like when it's someone else's choice to
become a mum if you want to keep the
baby because you don't think an abortion
is right then that's your choice okay so
you you would never change your mind on
that okay
um well today we're going to try
um so you have a video oh no I'm I no
sorry what I don't want to oh okay it's
um you can go it's okay
um but um yeah if you have a video you
want to show right okay could you show
the next video oh just quickly what's
your position on this
oh I mean I'm pro-life but um I heard an
interesting argument the other day that
made me think
um it was like by Destiny where he it
was something with like brain function
so I will say like you know I could be
more educated on the science so that's
that's actually why she came on my show
the other day and I just thought it'd be
interesting to like learn what they had
to say
and it changed recently what your
opinion changed no I'm still pro-life
I'm still pro-life but it was just an
interesting argument where I was like
um I'd have to find the video but it was
by Destiny he was doing like pro-life
pro-choice and Destiny's such a good
debater and I was just like oh I've
never thought about it that way
but no I I'm still I wouldn't say I
changed my mind I'm still pro-life
can I ask you a question so both of you
guys are pro-life
um I didn't catch your name as uh Ruth
Ruth Ruth
um so for example my auntie
um she had twins when they were born but
one of the twin
um was in critical condition and then
when he was finally born he was on life
support
the doctor told my auntie he's going to
suffer the rest of his life being on
life support like feeding him through a
tube and whatnot what do you want to do
and it was a very difficult decision and
she just had to let one of the twins die
and
I know like you might say that's wrong
but I think there are certain
situations you can allow abortion great
um
that if they're suffering I mean I don't
I don't I wouldn't say yes for like oops
I wouldn't say yes for like the
euthanasia where it's like an adult
dying because you're pretty much at the
end and all you have to do is just fight
through the end and then you know you
can state that you didn't commit suicide
kind of thing in a in a sense um but
then again if it's if it's a baby being
born and it's gonna suffer for the
entire life
I think uh that is one other condition
that I would stand with abortion um
or letting the baby die so that's it so
so you're pro-life with like a couple
exceptions
basically yeah and I also want to get
your view on what would you do if you're
a mother and you've just had a child and
that child is going to suffer for the
rest of its life with um like it's sick
yeah
um your feeding tube
um whatever so what would you do I
actually had a cousin that was in that
situation
um
I mean I would just do everything I
could to keep him alive and if he died
he died like I mean I just think I'd
have a hard time like killing killing my
kid
um personally
but no I had a cousin and he was only
supposed to live till he was three and
he lived until he was like 12.
um but it wasn't a good quality of life
it was actually really hard to watch so
um I could see why it would be like hard
for someone to go through my other
cousin as well um from my mom's side
this time uh she's she was born as well
as a twin funny enough and she was
paralyzed from birth or actually no she
was okay but the doctor or the hospital
didn't give her enough oxygen when she
was born so she started um her brain
didn't send the correct signals to her
body so she was just paralyzed now um
she suffers in other words in other ways
so she's growing up seeing her brother
uh move in and walking running playing
football and she's always going to be on
a wheelchair do you know what I mean and
like I don't know how to explain this to
you but she really hates life you know
there's only a few things in life that
make her happy Maybe music seeing her
family food but then most of the time
she's just suffering because she can see
the world and she can see what she
doesn't have
and then again
like this can be avoided at the very
early stages
and uh not like obviously I'm happy to
have her in my life and I love her as my
cousin but you know I can see her
suffering yeah and the family as well
well I just think doctors can be wrong
and that's like where I would have a
hard time like if they say they'll have
this disease and they might not yeah
yeah there's so many so many situations
where that's happened the Rain Man uh
where where they've yeah doctors have
diagnosed something in the womb and the
mothers have refused all they said the
baby's gonna live this long and the
mothers have refused abortion and their
children are healthy and fine you know
there's doctors get it wrong give so
what would you guys do then if you're in
that situation so I think Paul gave me a
heart what would you do if your daughter
or son was born and then you have to
make a decision whether they should live
or not the same thing I could never kill
my child okay
um I just I would hope and pray
that my child got better I felt like oh
sorry no no no go ahead are you finished
yeah no I was gonna say I feel like
happiness is also inside a lot of people
get it confused where they're watching
the outside too much and they're
requiring all this temporary happiness
like oh when I get money I'll be happy
or when this or when I do this but
actually it's just inside if we search
for happiness inside we we will be happy
but a lot of people compare themselves
to other people's lives and things like
that but I do like I would never
understand someone who's obviously
disabled or severely
um unwell you know it's it's quite
difficult but again we don't know what
the afterlife is no one knows but if
they're alive here today
maybe there'll be another sort of life
for them no one actually knows because
none of us has died so you know but but
we just don't know but it's a good point
yeah
yeah I was just gonna say I've got two
things I'll just want to go back to what
Cass said earlier on about having the
right support
um in place
um because you work in mental health as
you mentioned I did yeah oh you did
before okay
um and I think it's similar with the
abortion issue and
um for a woman that finds out that she's
pregnant
um I think a lot of it is based on being
properly informed about the process
you're going through
um so that you can come to a um informed
decision I feel like
um from my experience
um having an abortion when I was 19 I
wasn't properly informed like
abortion is something that is classified
as a medical procedure
and with most medical procedures that
you do have and I've had a few
um in my lifetime
um nothing severe but you are informed
about what the procedure is going to be
you are informed about
um you've shown images of what you're
going to have done and I feel like
abortion is sidelined oh yeah it's not
you don't you're not properly informed
no so for me my experience I came out
the other side and there was a lot of
mental trauma
um and there was a lot of healing there
was a lot of healing process and the
support I think is very important if you
do decide to have an abortion
um as it was in my case and I didn't
feel like I had that at that time and
just to go back to what ruby was saying
um about your your family situation
there's a guy I can't remember his name
and he's literally he was born without
no limbs like he has no arms no legs and
he was actually
um he's on YouTube he's a big YouTuber
and I mean his life is phenomenal know
and it's going back again where where
what does happiness look like how do we
define happiness he's in this world and
he's impacting this world and like Leaps
and Bounds and he was born that way he
did mention that when he was I think it
was 10 or 12 that he wanted to commit
suicide I can't remember what he stated
what got him over that hurdle but he's
still here today and he's living he's
living a
fulfilled life do you know what I mean
so I think it's it's about having the
right support it's about being well
informed
um and um
yeah I just feel that there is other
options do you know what I mean having
the right mentality yes definitely is
key to life definitely definitely um but
yeah I I must go back on that as well
what you just said um I've had an
abortion myself and again they they
don't really inform you of the procedure
they will say okay yeah you get a pill
and then or you get the vacuum and then
that's it but actually when when I did
get the pill and they said it's all
going to come out don't worry you know
and it will come out and it was a little
baby you know and it's like whoa I
wasn't ready for that you know and it
was just it was shocking you got you got
the pill I got the the pill yeah so how
does that I I know
um once it's surgical they like pull off
the limbs and then vacuum yeah but I
don't I don't actually know as much
about the pill so so the pill so you get
like a couple of them right
um and the like first it wasn't even
like I felt something was stuck so I had
to go go back there and they had to like
take out with a
um what's it called them
forceps yeah yeah that was my first um
abortion and I had a second one and um
it was it was a pill and you know and
um I decided to go ahead and it was the
worst experience ever because they they
did not inform me that a whole child
would come out of there you know and I
would think it would be in part so I
wouldn't see it you know and it was a
full little child it was the size of my
palm but it was such a horrible
experience you know and I've seen it I
I've seen it and and that mental picture
again you have to train your mind to
forget that you can't you know when
people go through abortions and they
have PTSD from it I say like the best
thing you can do is to there's ways to
forget about it ways to never think
about it again ways to sort of you know
erase that from your memory but but they
don't tell you anything like that they
never did and I always tell the women
you know that go for abortions are just
just telling you this is what it is you
know and they're like oh really you know
and then they come back like I regret it
so much you know but
yeah they should be more informative 100
how far along were you I I was like four
weeks you're only four no sorry no that
uh this um escape the when the when the
baby came out yeah oh that one was about
six or eight weeks something really so
six or eight weeks and because they they
say it's like a feed like a clump of
cells basically yeah it was awful baby
and it was like the site it had arms it
had legs it had a head and it was intact
so it wasn't like wow and it wasn't like
it was parts of it it was literally
all of it and and so um because I I what
I understand about the pill and you guys
you too know more than I do about this
but it's like basically it starves the
kid to death right and then it did like
where did it happen at the hospital or
were you at home uh no so this happened
at the hospital yeah so you take one at
home and then like you said I didn't
know it would stop the child right so
but yeah you take one at home then you
come I think it's the next day or in two
days and then you have another pill and
it's meant to come out of you and
whatnot well and it is does it always
come out at the hospital if you do the
pills I think some people have done it
at home and it they just it goes down
the toilet you know oh okay that's what
they say so since the pandemic
um basically they allowed they changed
the law to allow these abortion pills to
be sent by post to people's homes which
causes all sorts of issues because many
women don't know how far along they are
so you're only meant to have the pills
up to about 10 weeks and um you know
there's been stories of people having it
at 12 13 14 15 weeks and ended up in
hospital and hemorrhaging and things
like that and so yeah just being sent
and they yeah they're literally saying
the instructions to flushed the baby or
the products of conception down the
toilet so yeah I'm sorry you had to see
that that must have been no sorry like
you have to sort of oh my God over that
I know wow yeah um do you want to show
the video I actually have not seen this
video I don't know what it is
what do you think about abortion each
individual is up to them what they want
to do I think everybody should be around
them right I'm not really foreign or
against you everyone has their right to
kind of do what they call is right in
their own life so what I want to show
now is a short one minute video of what
an abortion procedure looks like at
various stages from 10 to 24 weeks
[Music]
is two things
[Applause]
sorry I didn't know I could do it yeah
I'm sorry I can't look at it
sorry
[Music]
[Music]
so that's the video
these babies are finished
they had hands I didn't know I was like
that that's a body that's a shoe that's
that's a whole no full grown man it's
fully developed
that [ __ ] that really shouldn't be right
that's technically even though the baby
may not be out as technically I'll
relate that to murder
on
[Music]
I'm a bit speechless actually it is a
person and people don't realize that a
lot of people think oh is this a bunch
of cells in that to the point but you
know three months and on you can really
see the formation and everything so yes
[Music]
so
um is abortion like footage suppressed
on Google or something because I tried
to do a show
um uh like I haven't done abortion in a
while but I did this in the summer I
think and I like could not find a lot of
images on it like at all
yeah um
well is some yeah is definitely
suppressed somewhat they'll probably on
social media they'll probably blur it
out or because I mean in YouTube we had
an abortion video up and they took it
down on YouTube but then we kind of said
well you know you say it's a medical
procedure so why can't we have medical
procedures on YouTube so they reinstated
it but covered it or it was only a few
subscribed and over 18. so yeah it's
definitely suppressed definitely
suppressed but you can see you know when
people see it they really do change
their minds and you know people can go
to abortionreality.com and see abortion
for themselves
when you say we roof sorry I know we've
never met before who do you represent or
work for what is your oh I work for an
organization called CBR UK so the center
for bioethical reform UK is where human
rights organization and does that
represent like All Humans of course I've
never heard yeah we stand up for we
educate on the humanity of The Unborn
Child and the reality of abortion we
support women who've been through it
yeah
I'm just like I keep thinking about the
kid that came out it was it was crazy
because I'm just shocked at like six
weeks like that's not far at all yeah
like when I Googled six weeks it didn't
see what it didn't show me what I
birthed basically
um you know what I think some of the
confusion with ages is that when you're
pregnant they use LMP which is your last
menstrual period yep so actually when
you conceive so say my last menstrual
period was you know mid-october
um that's not when you conceive because
you don't know when you've had sex and
stuff so actually the the baby is
normally conceived about two weeks after
if that makes sense so so a lot of the
the images that we use we date and your
baby was was would have been from
um conception yes you said you said six
or eight weeks yeah yeah
they had everything yeah it had
everything yeah would I have done it if
I knew that no
no but but it's like but like again like
I I am for life right pro-life right but
at the same time like it's it's
someone's Choice it's like even coming
out with abortions and saying if someone
wants to kill someone on the street they
can it's their choice and that's sort of
what I'm saying right but it's still not
legal yeah it's not legal exactly yeah
because people need to be protected
right yeah do you do you guys
um think that women that get abortions
should be
um pursued to the fullest extent of the
law
what's up with me so if um for the
pro-life people here
I think we should uh prosecute the
doctors because at currently uh the as
we've heard from the panel the doctors
know for well what they're doing they
know it's a human being and they know
that they're what they're going to do to
that human being is going to kill it so
I think we should prosecute the doctors
and the abortion
um industry uh not the women because
most of the women are not fully informed
as we've already discussed okay
um
sorry you have to run that question by
me again um do you think that women if
um they were to Outlaw abortion do you
think women that get abortions should be
pursued to the fullest extent of the law
um
well that would put me in that category
wouldn't it but um I meant moving so
like if they if they pass a law tomorrow
they can't per like put someone in jail
from before the law was passed so it
would just be like women in the future
you know like if you change the speed
limit to 50 and it was 40 last week they
don't say you drove 45 last week no
um I I
I just think that you know
fat woman
doesn't have the full picture
so therefore as it stands anyway so
therefore
similar to what Ruth is saying
the the doctors that are signing off
these women to or permitting them to
have these abortions
um and those that are actively perform
in the abortions should be held to
account now I'll just say something very
quickly from my own experience was that
from my understanding there should have
been two signatures to permit my
abortion and there wasn't what was the
second one sorry so what signature they
normally you normally have two
signatures
um so one doctor would
um
sign and in other words
counter sign to authorize the abortions
yeah
in this nation so that wasn't the
situation that I that wasn't my own
personal experience it was very much
in the hospital consultation I mean that
I'm pregnant and the first thing that
was offered to me was an abortion
um I just feel like they
they should be other options given to
that woman
so yeah because you were 19. I was nice
and so that was the first thing yeah
okay yeah
um yeah so
you're very I can see it like still
affects you it does it does um so it's
just going back to what Cass said you
know you say you train your mind to
forget but like we're here today it's
it's part of my tapestry it I I can't
forget I could I've moved on with my
life I have been healed from my
experience
but
I like most traumas you can't forget it
it's just you learn to cope and you
learn to forgive yourself for it that's
what people say right that's what
everyone says but the brain is capable
of everything the brain is like a
computer if you tell um like you know
you have to organize it in certain
folders if you don't want something on
the computer you can move it to the bin
folder and and people don't realize that
I've had a lot of things happen to me
and and most of the things I've actually
forgotten about until I actually come
and speak on these subjects and people
bring these subjects up I'm like oh yeah
that's happened to me oh oh yeah like
I'm really good with those things
um so what I would do is I would like if
the memory comes back again it's very
good to start off with for forgiveness
forgiving yourself forgiving whatever
the doctors no signatures or all those
things yeah absolutely that's the first
step but the second step is working with
your brain your brain communicates to
you through your imagination therefore
you should respond with your imagination
so when that memory comes you can
imagine scrunching it putting into the
bin folder your brain will adapt your
brain will know it you are the engineer
of of that computer you are the engineer
of your life your brain thinks it can
control you only because you haven't
taken that power
but no one knows that you know everyone
just lets the brain do everything the
amount of thoughts that we get every day
and it could be so Random like random
thoughts that don't even belong to our
personality you know but but we can
control that we can and and things like
that happen to us we don't need to think
about it we don't need to feel the pain
every time like it's happened to you so
long ago and I can feel it in your chest
in in your emotions it's still there and
it's still resurfacing you know so if
you just practice this I'm scratching up
putting into the bin folder
um trust me the brain will adapt quicker
than you think and eventually it will
stop showing up like the whole memory
will just disappear
um in my case I don't want it to
disappear only because I share my
experience with other women
um
so it allows them to understand that
there is hope there is healing so
although I'm emotive when I speak about
it it's not because I'm like holding on
or dwelling to it dwelling yeah on it
it's because I
allow myself and I told myself that
because of what I experienced and
because I wasn't well informed and
because I knew how long it took me to
heal the trauma that I had from it I
want to be able to share my experience
with other people so I do share it on a
lot of platforms anyway I mean yeah like
I share my experiences as well right but
it's like that memory really just
disappears and it's only when I want it
to return it returns it's like the brain
doesn't just give it to me like it used
to no not on the daily Bible you know
they walk around daily thinking oh gosh
I had an abortion have you noticed
there's like two types of girls that
like after abortion like one gets like
really caught up about it and one
doesn't even seem to care and I don't
maybe she's just fronting but I wonder
if it's like an evolutionary adaptation
because historically
um if if you got like taken by another
tribe they would kill the women in the
church like they would take the women
and kill the children
and that's like why that I think it's
like might be an evolutionary adaptation
um
you think that women should be
prosecuted if they have an abortion
um
yeah I think if um I I think that the
information should be out there but if I
think if they outlawed abortion moving
forward they should because a full like
life sentence in jail yeah
um if they because to me it's you either
believe it's a life or you believe it's
not a life and if you believe it's a
life if we like under the law if we
recognized uh like I don't want to say
fetus but like the baby as like a life I
just think it would only make sense to
prosecute it to the fullest extent of
the law so that life can't look after
itself
like if you're not able as a life to
look after another life how are you to
be expected to do that I mean neither
can a two-day-old baby but you get
prosecuted to the fullest extent of the
life you kill the baby what about
um like children like young girls that
have been like great so essays like say
you're 11 or 12 and you know you fall
pregnant what happens if a 11 or a 12
year old had an abortion would you put
hair in jail or murder
um I mean I try to avoid like the worst
case scenarios because 40 of abortions
um they've had one or more so it's not
like a one-time
like a one-time situation in less than
one percent of abortions are for grape
um but I think it's kind of the similar
to if um but it can happen no okay I'm
gonna answer don't worry
um it's kind of similar to if a kid is
too young like they can go to juvie
um but no I mean it it's really like sad
but I just think that if you're gonna
recognize it as a life like it has to be
consistent legally
can I ask you that question back because
I can see you've got like a real heart
of compassion you know but um in terms
of if you if we were to make abortions
illegal except for grape sexual abuse
so sorry
um and all of these difficult cases
disability then would you agree that we
make it illegal for for just say
contraception um using it as
contraception or just because
no still no I still say it's the woman's
Choice up until the day that you're
allowed to it it has to be what human it
is it is interesting because people
often hide behind these difficult cases
um when actually you know you're the
reason is that you you'd be quite happy
for a woman to have an abortion just
because maybe she wants to go on holiday
and if she doesn't if she has a baby it
will interrupt her planned holiday
is that a good word is that a good
reason obviously that's not a good
reason but but what I'm not saying just
use abortion as like a form of
contraception but I'm saying like what
but why not
well what was wrong with that why why
not use it as a form of contraception
it's not like it kills a child well no
but I just think that's just like
irresponsible if you were like going out
every weekend getting pregnant and then
like the next week or next month just
going to the clinic and getting an
abortion like but why not what's wrong
what's wrong with abortion that you've
recognized that it shouldn't be used as
contraception well I mean it probably
just wouldn't would that even be healthy
for a woman if she was getting an
abortion like I mean neither are plan
B's but girls be taking those every
other day
it's called like there's something to
think about you know yeah it is but like
I said I don't think my opinion would
change
contraception is a prevention
yep yeah and abortion isn't
I think men should have these pills
because they can get 365 women pregnant
in a year and a woman can only get
pregnant oh easier I think that's a big
spread our seed okay I think
I feel like there's a like I don't know
why they haven't come up with that yet
they haven't they have they have but men
decline but they won't take it no like
it had two that one that's what they say
but it had too many side effects like it
would not like the women no I'm talking
like it's sterilized I got like it was
actually like too much yeah it was that
I don't remember off the top of my head
but it was actually really bad
um I don't remember one guy that got
sterilized or die like something really
serious happened and it wasn't that big
of a sample size so like if it was one
out of 20
you know that that might happen to you
you probably aren't going to take it
but I'm butchering that that's just like
off the top of my head
um do you guys think that men should
have a say in abortion so
um further for the pro-choice people so
if you get pregnant and um the father of
the kid wants you to keep it should he
have any say
like if I was in a serious relationship
um
I mean of course he can have his opinion
but
I think like I said it's
down to the woman
to do whatever she wants to do so even
if he said no I don't want you to get an
abortion I think even if she wants to
get one she should still be able to get
one because at the end of the day it's
hey let's carrying the baby
um yeah
okay let's give him birth so yeah I
think it's her choice yeah I would agree
with you and also like who's human
rights are we
thinking about here you know your whole
life changes if you have a baby
like if I run out for a woman yeah for
all parties involved they're not even
just the man and the woman the superior
what a wider family and the child what
if the dad says like uh you don't once
you give birth like you don't have to
I'll take care of it I don't I don't
need you to do anything else like I got
it can you carry it for me can you buff
it for me
can you change your body for me
do you know how many times you hear
about like dad's running out on like
single like mums and they're like oh I
swear it took two of us to meet this kid
like come back here and like look after
the kid so that is acceptable for the
woman to see but when it comes to like
deciding on who's like gonna have the
baby no no it's definitely my choice
this is what I mean and then like oh
like I didn't even expect us to go into
the whole men and women's type of debate
and I thought we were going to stick to
abortion but it's again like it's just
double standards isn't it you know you
guys want basically everything and then
more and you don't carry it you don't
have to you don't you don't carry it but
what's worse though carrying it or
paying for it for the rest of its life
and paying non-stop child support paying
everyone so you're saying that women
don't pay for their children
well I'm saying well most of the time if
the man is involved he's paying for very
much everything right if he's a student
no if he's a supporting that if he's
disappointed as supporting means
supporting the person that's actually
doing
sorry
if I'm in the kid's life I'm gonna have
to make sure I'm working to look after
that kid subjectively yeah not
objectively wait hold on say that again
that's you subjectively yeah well I'm
just talking about what a high value man
would want to do for their wife I don't
want personally a high value man would
want to do but statistically is that
what happens well yeah so why there's so
many single mothers in this country man
no they're single mothers because women
are irresponsible
like in terms of what do you mean like
irresponsible it's actually
you're in control of who you have sex
with you are so if you've chosen to have
sex with a man that isn't someone that
would actively support you that makes
you what exactly irresponsible you're
responsible for
any kind of choice yeah because yeah you
have you have 10 choices the men have
one you you have the choice like you
know when you're ovulating you have the
choice to get an abortion you have 41
forms of birth control to choose from
the man has condom or no condom
that's a choice right
you're right but I'm saying I'm saying
the women have more Choice than the men
so it's more on us we're in control of
who who we have sex with so coming back
to the original question was like should
man have a choice when it comes to
abortion 100 based on that opinion um
right I mean you guys are perfect for
equality right so why can't we go Pals
just literally said with her own words
that's our responsibility so why would
you get a safe responsibility I said
it's um we have more choices so we are
more responsible so if we're more
responsible why do we not have the same
percentage of choice okay but you're
only having that large percentage of
choice while it's in your stomach right
and that's all you're debating but what
happens when it comes out yeah I said
who's who's responsible for birth yeah
pregnancy birth both plus I feel like
it's hot like it's the egg and the sperm
it's not just yeah it's like half half
right so it's like it takes two to tango
right but if it's 50 50 then why are we
more responsible because we carry it
I'm saying if there's an unplanned
pregnancy like we as women we have so
much more Choice than the men so like we
can we can do abstinence if we want like
we all could have waited till we were
married you know we we can also um we
also have the choice to require the men
that we sleep with wear condoms we could
do that we could also we also have the
choice to get on birth control you can
get an IUD you can get a pill that thing
in your arm I know there's side effects
but that's that's our choice right
um on top of that we also can be wise
with who we sleep with and not sleep
with anyone that wouldn't be not a good
father we also have the choice to get an
abortion we also have the choice to put
a man on child support we also have the
choice to get married and leave and then
take half
um we also get more child support if we
take away the kids from the dad so we're
financially incentivized to take away
the children so they have all of the we
have all of this choice and the men have
condom or no condom so it's like if we
have 10 choices that's a pre-pregnancy
choice that the man has post pregnancy
Choice it would depend a lot a lot of
the things yeah of course we have that
choice but divorce doesn't just get you
don't just automatically get half based
on absolutely nothing like if you're a
woman that's like worked and certain
amount of money it does come down yeah
and certain numbers there's there's a
small percentage of women but women
don't typically make more than men that
we we make less and we spend more and
there's also um I just learned about
this the other day there's
um lawsuits going on in the U.S where
they overestimate how much it costs to
raise a child basically just so they can
get more child support in court so
they'll say like it costs this much to
raise a child even though like for
example let's do Kanye West and Kim
Kardashian like why does that girl and
and she out earns him and he's a
billionaire and he still has to pay how
much in child support yeah 200k a month
and that's a billionaire woman so what
happens to the average man if if a
multi-millionaire that married a
billionaire can't escape child support
so you believe that a man shouldn't have
any say in an abortion or [ __ ] based on
the fact that you acknowledge
no I'm saying like we're more
responsible for an unplanned pregnancy
like it's more of our fault
and we actually avoid the responsibility
after because we get we make the men pay
for our poor choices so you think that
they should have more say in abortions
or not
um I think that abortion if it was up to
me it would be illegal yeah so
um I don't think anyone should ever say
but if it was to be that what would be
your like if that if abortions were not
illegal and you were on the side of uh
approach that was pro-choice you would
think that it would have to be a
signature from the man and the woman for
unable to enable the actual like
surgical or procedure to continue based
on the facts
um
but see that's hard because I wouldn't
even I wouldn't be pro-choice to begin
with so why is the question like
relevant why because you're pro-choice
that's what I was asking yeah
um but if if you're pro-life like you
don't believe in abortion to begin with
so you wouldn't even get there so it's
not about the masculine and feminist
purely based on it's just like like
feminist fought for equality here it is
what guys are guys that are for pro-life
right so when I got pregnant twice I was
actually on um anti- contraception
um how would you how would you react to
that like obviously
um I was on pills okay yeah and I was
taking them regularly and both of the
times I even changed my pills just to
make sure you know if a different one
and and both of the times I actually got
pregnant so it's it's kind of difficult
like when you actually don't touch after
the first time
um what do you mean after the first like
pregnancy you didn't switch birth
control I did I did that's why I said I
tried different ones yeah and then the
the other one is a different one and it
still didn't work and I looked
specifically just to check like I made
sure that I took one I even had an alarm
set you know and it is what would you
say to them I'm curious why don't you
get an IUD that's like that's the most
effective one also um
I don't know oh is that what you guys
call here the corner yeah I had a clue I
had a coil
um but it went um it got stuck um and I
couldn't breathe I had to they didn't
even know that it um it was that it was
stuck under it was attached to one of
the womb tissues or something it was so
painful and I kept saying like
something's wrong and they were like no
nothing's wrong you ain't had children
so it's it's not that you know and I had
to actually go privately pay for X-rays
and then they told me no it's that and
they had to to get it out I mean I just
think um you also only ovulate three
days a month so I think you can track
your ovulation um I think you can wear
condoms and I think you cannot have sex
yeah that's another thing but yeah and I
just think like I'm just a big fan of
like you kind of made your bed lie in it
and at some point like something went
wrong yeah
um but you can't see I can I come in I
don't see it from the same perspective
as you know
I know a lot of people that's like you
know just trying to justify you know I I
was on the pill and all this um simple
biology
sex creates like children can not always
but it's it's cause and effect and I
just think we've and I get it I say this
as a as someone who who got pregnant and
had a child at 22 that typical age
um and um yeah it's like
is is we've lost we've lost that in
society it's like it's my right to have
sex with who I want and
um not have any consequences and and I
find it hard to say that word consequent
because I
I was I was silly I made a mistake but I
have been blessed with a child and I've
got a beautiful daughter so I I don't
see it as oh that was my punishment or
that was my you know for for for being
careless
um but it's just I think we just need to
get back to the place of society as just
looking at what sex is and you know if
you don't want to have a child then
maybe
sex should be like you know if if you're
not ready to have a child then you know
that is also pleasure and having
Recreation so it's both it's two things
it's not just one yeah and but what's
what if you can have a child then surely
you want to ensure that the person
you're having sex with is someone that
you would be happy to have and raise a
child with
because because the opposite to that is
what we're left with today right and we
need to be able to kill out that's
definitely a female perspective because
a guy is not going to just have sex with
a woman who he's hoping to have a baby
with he's just gonna have sex with a
woman because yeah like I I just think
like you can wear condoms like if you're
on okay I'll give it to you if you have
condoms and birth control and you
tracked your cycle I will give you that
l oh but it's like if you didn't do all
three things like You're irresponsible
at some point
oh no I think she was trying to say um
because you said it was for you said it
was for pleasure and I'm saying yeah if
you want to have sex for pleasure fine
um you can do that but like be careful
and and I just think like if you didn't
do all three of those things like at
some point you were irresponsible
also Sexual Energy as well guys that's a
big one like
you don't know about this okay I'm not
going to say no because like yeah okay
you can wear a condom and it'll protect
you in in one way from STDs or creating
life and whatever but no condom is going
to protect you from transferring energy
it's an actual energy exchange ritual if
it makes sense what would two people
become one yeah yeah
um I have a question for you and you
don't you don't have to answer this um
the the two abortions was it the same
dad no there are two different two
different people yeah and what made you
think you couldn't have a kid with those
guys
um but like what she said it made me
realize what Ruth said it just made me
realize um
this was when I was younger by the way
so I've grown up a lot from how old with
each one so I was
17 on the first one and then I was
um 23
on the next one
um but yeah it just made me realize like
the the the second the first time like I
actually like I was actually having fun
right so that made me calm down I was
like I'm doing that so when you say
having fun it was like a casual it was a
casual so it wasn't anyone you were
serious with no so okay so then you
thought I can't have a kid with them
right yeah but but that made me realize
right the media it's those they kind of
project that onto people that the
original family is like the perfect
picture right but but it's not true I've
seen fathers who are not biological and
and they have the most amazing beautiful
families right so
um do you think he would have like stuck
around I don't know uh no no okay are we
spoken about that yeah and he said if
you have this I won't be there yeah yeah
yeah was he angry at you at all
um
I guess yeah there was some sort of like
you know
pause and whatnot but yeah I guess again
I was quite immature uh mentally at that
time and obviously the second time as
well it emotion mentally I was quite
immature as well I looked at things
differently and then it made me realize
okay next time I have sex I need to be
aware like do I want to have a baby with
this person do I want to marry this
person do I want to you know just all
these things sort of come up and I was
like I really need to think about those
decisions and and yeah and what about
the second guy were you with him or no
um yeah the second guy yeah so what made
you not wanna because it seemed like did
he love you or like he was in a
relationship so the the so we were
actually together before and then we
ended up coming back and then yeah so I
wasn't actually with him but we ended up
coming back and you dated him before
yeah and I was it was like my longest
relationship so is he was he a good guy
no oh okay no no no he wouldn't have
stuck around no he was no okay yeah
um so you did the same thing yeah did
the same thing yeah okay exactly so you
kind of grow up from it you sort of
learn the lesson and like I've been
celibate for so long now right because I
look at things so differently now when
it comes to sex and it's not just the
baby but it's the sexual energy is
everything is is sex is really really
sacred people think it's fun but it's
how long have you been celibate for
um if you want it you don't have to
answer this if you don't want to
um well it's it could have been a year
but it's now five months but it could
have been a year so I had a little bleep
but yeah okay okay yeah
um and then oh you also had an abortion
yeah can I ask you about it is it okay
yeah um what made you think you could
never kid with that guy are there a few
factors actually so
um number one was the guy that I was
with at the time was it was much
an older guy how old oh gosh that's 26
27. okay that's that's yeah you're 19.
yeah that's not so bad okay
um or if yeah if my mom is yeah yeah 26
27 or close yeah maybe about close to 30
or 30 anyway but he was much more older
than me
um and
I remember when we discussed
the whole I'm pregnant thing we stepped
out of the doctor's room and he said to
me oh you've got your whole life ahead
of you
um you're too young
um so
that put me off
um and then
I had I had a late term abortion there
so I was like 20 weeks
um I had left the country because I was
actually struggling with whether or not
I'm making the right choice
um also it was
um just how my peers would view me at
the time
and
um my family I have a very strong family
unit
the way I was raised
um I was raised from in a Christian home
and um
I just didn't want to disappoint my mum
uh
and I remember my my mum at the time she
made a statement
and that really just was like a deal
breaker for me I was just like oh if if
you
if you're saying it like that because
she didn't know outrightly but I think
just having a mother's intuition she
sort of she knew there was something
going on
and once she said that I was just like
oh I can't do this this is
I've
at the time I felt like I I wasn't
hearing what I wanted to hear which was
he was going to support me how am I
gonna cope
um
and yeah I went hasn't
went for the abortion
um did the guy like do you think he
would have stayed if you kept it
I don't actually know
you say actually no or you don't know no
I don't I don't know I mean I chose not
to continue a relationship with him so
after my experience so yeah I would know
um I'm just curious if it was a
different guy do you think he would have
been more likely to keep it
like to both of you
when you say a different guy I think if
it was a different guy who had like a
different
response I would have kept so if he had
the response that like I'll be there you
can keep it you would have you would
have kept I think so yeah okay and what
about if it was a guy that you were oh
sure you could have could have seen
yourself with long term maybe yeah like
I shouldn't really like it shouldn't
really make a difference right but I
guess yeah at the time yeah yeah yeah
but like I said I was quite immature
back then even when I had the little
bleep now it was actually someone that I
looked as to the future you know so it
was a bit different but um yeah I
probably would but it shouldn't really
come down to that is my point really no
I think
um that's what they say in like red pill
that abortion is um the ultimate like
hypergamy where it's like women
um want to be with the like best
long-term mate that they can
so I'm not really surprised by that
answer
can I come in I think what it shows as
well is that you know that we we call it
pro-choice but that choice is never made
in a vacuum you know it was it was the
pressures of those around the thoughts
and the and the feelings that are
particularly the man in in Laura's
instance her mother as well and even I
can say from my experience and um when
when I got pregnant and I told my family
um yeah I mean I was very blessed that
my
um Dad said to me
um yeah we're gonna be there for you
we're going to support you and I know
that that like helped me
um and so I think it's it is a societal
issue and I think this whole pro-choice
rhetoric um rhetoric it kind of puts
everything on the woman when as a
society you know abortion impacts
society and it is is there's so many
pressures there's just so many pressures
on the woman that the woman's left to
deal with a lot herself at the end where
you know what of the dad that wasn't
there to support what of the friends and
the family members that weren't there to
support we often hear uh women say you
know if I just had one person that say
you can do this or we'll be here for you
they might have made a different choice
yeah um it's interesting the girls I
know that have had abortions
um not I just met you guys so like but
like I don't
um
I don't think it was like like both of
them came from like pretty wealthy
families that could have helped them I
just think it was more of like life
inconvenience to be fair
I'm just at the time
but
yeah I think support for those women
isn't even just money though is it it's
emotional support it's just that well
because people can be rich and and could
potentially support but are they you
know these rich families can still say
you know it's going to look bad on our
family or you know there's all those
shame elements and
um that perfect
the the detached on that perfect that
dream for that perfect family that this
is an interruption from that
and so I just think there's a lot of
elements that come into it I'm going to
read super chats and then we'll watch
the second video
um
guys um thank you for this is the most
calm um ever show I've ever had on
abortion I was yeah you guys are great
um okay I'm gonna read the super chats
in one second like the video guys that's
the most important metric that YouTube
uses
um
to
to push out these streams okay are these
women dating with intention now
um 90 Frito pie please ask the panel are
you okay with women aborting babies of a
certain race no more names available one
um ex-girlfriend got an abortion and I
didn't want and I didn't want to I
supported her and I saw it in the bath
and at water and was never the same she
didn't care cannot see a kid today and
not think about it Ryan Edward and women
wonder why men are walking away Nanny
Frito pie on Pearl YouTube sensors hard
I can't write anything close to abortion
without adding numbers and symbols is
there any other way
I don't know um numbers guys you're out
child support and alimony is the state
ensuring that the child and woman
doesn't become a finite financial burden
to the state sell the investor if it was
a thousand men
in the trial run 124 died 59 developed
testicular cancer oh it was a thousand
men in the trial run 120 this is about
the male birth control I knew someone in
the chat would tell me um it was a
thousand men in the trial run 124 died
59 developed testicular cancer and a
hundred percent sterilization programs
have been cut by drug makers best
contraception is abstinence no bills no
pills and I got money on both sides
um The Savvy ninja it's easier to
control one AG versus millions of
soldiers on moblets Pearl I'm the guy
who's been a part of one or two
abortions but honestly something dies
inside of you when you do it you become
desensitized to be able to go through
the trauma of watching your child be
diced up Vinnie falico she chose I had
no say but I lost the child too numbers
guys zero I'm Pro personal sovereignty
but the outcome stats for abortions are
definitely worth examining black people
are 14 of the US population yet 4 40
percent of all abortions at a rate of
400 aborts per a thousand live births
yeah that's um
see we're in the UK so I wasn't going to
go too much into that but it's actually
really messed up when you look at like
the history of that stuff in the U.S
um the forest hearing the answers really
proved to me that Margaret Sanger won
she has more Eugenics and empowerment
issue and look where we are now the
black population will be doubled in the
United States without this human Scourge
On The World God save our souls Gary
Grant um there is pro-life and pro-death
this pro-choice thing is a farce um T is
the only term to ease the guilt of
murder top brass 88 women in The Madras
shirt I wonder how you feel about IVF in
the process where abortion may be
necessary to help maintain the health of
the uterus if a pregnancy were to sinew
um we can come back to that later
because that'd be interesting to ask you
I don't know anything about IVF
um Ivan dimitriav a parasite needs
another being to survive but it's still
on its own being and it's a it but it's
still its own being and alive if brain
waves start it's a human in my opinion
um zh judging life based on breathing
for oneself would mean that people on
breathing machines aren't human that
logic isn't logicing the cam from TMR
radio this is an excellent topic Pearl I
appreciate your channel so much and I
haven't been contributing as much as I
should be consider this the first of
many thank you or keep up the good work
that was a hundred dollar Super Chat so
we're gonna do a little bit yeah yeah
um Mo Blitz please tell the lady in the
back that a fetus is a Latin word for a
little baby that's a baby from the
moment the eggs and the sperm meet each
other um zh if irresponsible parents
have a child because they can't abort
and raise a menace to Society how do we
the people deal with them and all the
crime that they could bring Daryl Brooks
in the USA for example
a moblets if you have trauma and you
aren't ready to be a parent please don't
have sex it's that simple sex has been
so minimized that we forget that the
sole purpose of sex is for procreation
purposes DLC
um tough topic is needed I've reacted to
your videos and want to pay tribute keep
leading the front another hundred dollar
Super Chat
um Jay Heron um the Ruby guy is the real
g in the streets um how's Cheryl Alex
from 100 interviews is a producer
because everyone's story is popping his
classes music space and organization
think Sim conductor poet MC concierge
house host has a lifestyle Guru a like
Anna Bay can take someone from zero to a
hundred each of his three mentors is a
lifestyle Guru and shares one unique
class you can take a person's uh song
build them a lifestyle and that person
itself art actualizes a good MC knows
exactly the song Shayla teaches youngins
to be better because she's a motivator
classes are school teacher space and
organization priest
okay
so
um if you want to do the next video
blessing
so I'm going to try and speak to some of
the students if they want to put their
views across anyone we're on Facebook
live does anyone want to say anything
about why you're covering up
no can I ask why not
your body your choice
but you don't have to speak but you're
in front of our display so you are live
on Facebook never again
do you want to explain your sign at all
Nate
do you want to engage or try and change
my mind about abortion
no would you like me to see my mind
changed and maybe support abortion
no okay
um we have got warning graphic abortion
content yep it's very graphic isn't it
why'd you think it's so graphic
no comment
we've got our bodies our choice sing
that one again
abortion should be as early as possible
as late as necessary a woman's choice so
what as late as necessary is it up to
birth
you just want to block the Science Why
I don't want to engage the idea
yeah is that because there's no argument
for abortion
there's an argument yeah
of Oxford do you want to explain a
little bit what your assignments no no
do you want to change my mind on
abortion um no
okay
was that you roof yeah
has this podcast been like orchestrated
based on your guys's personal views of
Interest
oh she came on my shell and I just
thought it would be a good podcast
um
why would you go why would you go to a
place where you're holding your opinion
on a sign and not talk about it so
that's what we find we find that we we
educate on the as I said the reality of
abortion and the humanity of the child
and we find that often I get that
there's you know there's some confusion
there's pro-choice but there's some
people that are avidly pro-abortion and
they're really you know really support
abortion and um often they don't they
they don't have an argument and what
we'll find is they'll cover up the
reality of abortion yeah when and these
were Oxford University students so
they're meant to be some of the you know
smartest people in the world but they
wouldn't debate the issue so I think
it's just quite a telling
um do you have the pamphlets you brought
last time yeah can I see it yeah can you
grab it and you can take it off for a
second
um because that's actually what made me
want to do it with those pamphlets were
crazy
um
why do you think people get so heat
that's it's actually like you don't know
how in shock I am like this is the most
calm panel I've done this topic a couple
times and like I've never had this calm
of just like someone always gets mad but
why do you think people get so angry
about this topic in particular
um
well maybe people have been through it
themselves like being through abortion
themselves and you know they have
maybe something like traumatic happened
and
I don't know I guess
what was it why are people so sensitive
about yeah like I'm talking about
abortion I've just noticed them that
typically abortion is like
I do a lot of controversial topics on my
show but I swear to God outside of this
room it's that's always the most like
heated one
hmm I don't know does anyone else
an opinion on that
um I feel that it's because
you're faced with the reality really
um it's not nice to look at
so I feel like is that it's that thought
that out of sight out of mind so if it's
not shown then it's acceptable it's
tolerated but once it's out and you see
what abortion actually is then it Sparks
a debate it Sparks
I mean abortion process itself really if
you show the real reality of it it
protests itself it doesn't you don't
need to have to you don't need to really
say much I just can't believe this is
eight weeks if anyone wants to see like
the stages of development um I'm just
gonna pass it around
um because that that's like mad do you
guys think um that since women have the
right not to be mothers men should have
the right not to be fathers
yeah so since abortion is illegal that
men should be able to sign off um so
they never have to pay child support 100
yeah yeah
because it's their choice it's like it's
like I go with the again with the
abortion thing I I I still have uh the
pro-choice um answer because I still
feel like we're created to have that
Free Will and if we decide to do like
like you said you you you what did you
what's that quote are you late um you do
the bed you lay in it yeah yeah it's the
same sort of thing right so I still
believe like if the man said okay I
don't want to be involved then then this
is Choice really
um yes and for the pro-choice people
tell me where you think abortion should
be legal on the stages of development
how many weeks is it now currently like
so um in the UK it's interesting it's up
to six months but there's kids that have
survived um so it's legal up to 26 weeks
I think and there's kids that have
survived at 24.
um
honestly I guess if it's 26 weeks and
it's 26 weeks okay
what do you think
sorry which question so where do you
think abortion should um be legal at
like at what point
it has to be your choice
it has to be the choice of the person
this so if I enable in life so if I if I
you know like what human right are you
protecting you know are you protecting
the human right of the person that's
actually carrying it at what stage so so
I'm saying like if I wanted to get an
abortion I'm gonna give birth in three
days
so I'm saying like I think we'd have
some common ground on like where it
should be like at least at certain
points at eight months nine months it
should be illegal so I'm saying at what
point would you mark that life is life
why
is it uh is it 24 that it is illegal or
is it 22. I know it's got 22. is 24
weeks it's 24 weeks but classified as
illegal but if there's any kind of
perceived abnormalities right up until
birth and so there's actually
um statistics I can't remember the top
of my head where you know with the Down
Syndrome or even cleft lip palette I
don't know what that is
um
yeah that's that's a perceived yeah
Beyond 24 weeks you can get so if if
someone had a clef like because that's
when your when your lip is just yeah but
they can fix that yeah yeah yeah and so
that is that in the UK and the us or
just the UK I don't know about the US
wow yeah so there's what did they base
that decision on like why have have they
why why has someone in a laboratory or
some sort of assumingly scientific field
decided that that is the age before like
giving an opinion on why and what I
think it used to be 28 and then when
because you think this it was 1967 when
the abortion act come came in and
um actually when it first came in it
didn't come in to to give you a a right
you know like it's different to America
where it was deemed a riot
um it was actually for extreme
situations and that's why what Laura
mentioned about you need to have two
doctors because there's actually to to
sign off whether they think you should
be able to have one and it's under
things like if you're if the um to
continue with the pregnancy is going to
impact your mental health or your
physical health so at what point was the
mental health lack disregarded as a it's
still there so most of the abortions
that actually happened today by the
letter of the law in this nation are
illegal or probably illegal because most
people think that we have abortion on
demand but we don't yeah they're meant
so there's all sorts of things where the
abortion clinics pre-science forms and
stuff like that but that thing that
Laura said is very true that two doctors
are meant to sign off and give you a you
know a woman a kind of a consultation to
see whether they think that that there
is some going to be some mental issues
so what point is that like not an
acceptable reason
sorry I I don't understand your question
so at what point is the psychological uh
state of a human being
become like uh
so if we're I think I understand your
question but if we're pro-life it's
consistent so it doesn't matter whether
it has a risk to the person's life
carrying the life
um
yeah I mean I I personally don't know
enough about those situations I would
say I could be educated more on that
stuff but I I think if
from what I understand there's like very
few situations that that actually
happens so one situation would be for
example if you had a ectopic pregnancy
yeah yeah so that's uh Fallopian tubes
yeah so the so the kind of the embryo
hasn't made it up to the to the womb to
implant and the women implants into the
fallopian tube and that's dangerous
right women and the child's not going to
survive because it can't grow and you
know and continue to develop in the
fallopian tube so what will happen is
the the baby will die and the mother
will die so what they do babies should
be allowed to die and that and that is
life-saving so the intent of that is to
save life right so it's to save life if
we could well both lives but I mean
sorry to say save the mother's life
through so in that situation you would
agree that that would be yeah and I
don't it's not even considered it's a
very different procedure so they what
they do is they go in and they cut the
fallopian tube and take it out so it's
not even what is it won't be in the
abortion stats it doesn't classify as an
abortion no because that's life-saving
treatment yeah so what would you do if
it was Mother versus child like say if
it like other was pregnant and it was in
the right area but they said
um yeah I think I think the oh the the
purpose should always be to save life
where you can save life right so so if
you can't save if you can't save the
uh would you mean a mother over the
child so like if Cass is saying that
like if it was a situation where the
doctor had assumingly said to someone
that wasn't even the mother because at
this point I'm assuming she doesn't
actually have the ability to communicate
necessarily and
I can't save you and your child what do
I do what would I mean these are
hypothetical situations I mean they not
exist I know there's a there's a group
of doctors in in Ireland that that they
say that actually abortion
um I mean that ectopic pregnancy is is
something different because we're
talking about elective abortion right
where a woman goes to have an abortion
about all abortions just so in terms of
the ones to save there's a group of
doctors in Ireland and they say that
abortion is never necessary to um save a
mother they would continue to birth a
child even if the mother was to die I
said that they say that there's never a
situation where abortion is necessary so
for example let's take
um is it pre-eclampsia which happens
quite later on in pregnancy or there's
some things that happen Okay so so if
something happens later in pregnancy
it's a late term abortion is very is
actually very dangerous for the woman
because she now has they have to go in
there have to rip you know the baby's
limbs apart they have to crush the skull
and to and she then she has to give
birth
to that um dead baby
no it's cheap it's it's easier to induce
the woman let her and let her give birth
to the baby this is where I'm talking
late term six months on it's easier to
to for her to give birth it would be
more dangerous for the woman to go
through a late term abortion than it
would for her to go through with her
birth so you would carry a dead baby for
the last three months of your pregnancy
or if I misunderstood no after six
months so after six months the baby can
survive outside the womb in a um
so then they'll you give birth to the
baby and then put the baby in the
incubator Force the pregnancies
so abortion won't save that woman's life
because that's a two-day procedure so
there's this there's a lot of these lies
that have been going going around that
are put out by the abortion industry
things like even the stats that they
said we're going to go back to
Backstreet abortions they were conflated
and it's been proven by abortionists the
the guy who came up with those stats
he's now changed and he's now pro-life
and he's yeah and the Bug Guy
um in and you can Google it I've
forgotten his name apologies but they
said that these stats were made up so I
actually don't know what are the back
alley stats tell me about that
um I don't know this that's the actual
stats but but that's one of the
arguments you'll hear okay if we make
abortion illegal you're going to go back
to they're going to go back to back Ali
abortion okay but um the thing is we've
got these pills now and the and the
appeals the pills are just being sent by
post anyway so that in a way the
abortion industry has put it back to to
back early abortions by Distributing
these pills for people to do it I didn't
even think about that in their homes
but yeah the the the stats that they
gave that all these women are going to
die if they don't get abortions they
were all um made up
and could totally the guy came forward
saying he that he made them up yeah I
think he it was narrow n-a-r-a-l sorry I
don't know the guy's name okay and he he
said he made up the stats yeah they he
was part of the group and they they they
were propaganda why do you think they do
that because when you're trying to the
the agenda was to you know make my body
my choice right and bring abortion in
because before abortion was legal most
people weren't for abortion right right
it wouldn't be like it is today because
it wasn't scientifically possible
they hadn't successfully done it so
there were things happen like people
would take herbs you know throughout
history there's been ways that people so
there's always been a desire so it was
possible yeah I mean there's been
there's been ways but in terms of most
of society weren't for abortion but when
you change the law how come it does the
law can some abortional for against it
that do we have like statistics and like
votes on like well well the pro or
caution when they wanted to do it I'm
sorry do we um so like pre the date of
abortion like being like a physical uh
surgical procedure do we have like stats
of like questionnaires and you know did
we go and speak to these people to
decide whether or not they actually were
before or against it like where is that
well just information come from I mean
just from the fact that they had to do
this big push and propaganda to try and
change it so if we just talk about this
country when they first put abortion in
it was safe it was under the name of the
phrase of safe legal and rare
so not my body my choice let's come in
later so it was like okay this is an
awful thing but we need it for just
certain very rare situations and that's
what that's what abortion because
Society wasn't any place for like what
so it didn't originally start out of
like you could just because you wanted
it but no it was it started legal in
place for certain circumstances only and
it still is that's what I was saying
earlier it still is but I don't
understand what you mean so so uh you're
saying that it was only in place for
certain circumstances and you're saying
that it still only is legal you can go
into the if okay what the law was is
basically before then it was a 1967
abortion act in this nation before that
there was something called the offenses
against the person act which is from the
1800s and this offenses against the
person act protects all of us from all
sorts of crimes against us protects us
protects me from killing you protects
you from you know and one of the one of
the Clauses in that is that it's illegal
to procure an abortion in so we have
that that law never changed so we still
have a law in this nation that makes
abortion illegal so what the 1967
abortion act did it didn't let the
states give us a fundamental right to
abortion but it brought in exceptions
and you can Google people can Google 96
7 abortion act and you'll see that uh
like
yeah we've got this law that says
abortion is illegal but these are a list
of exceptions when a woman can have an
abortion so what is it on the list of
exceptions that's so
High that's enabling this is the mental
health so some of them are like to say
the life of the mental health uh
dismissed as a human right but they just
they just say mental health for all
sorts of things so there was an
undercover
um sting that the the some people did by
the Telegraph and they went into a
doctor's surgery and this woman said you
know I'm pregnant and I've got a girl
and I don't want a girl I I want a boy
um can I have an abortion and by the law
he shouldn't have said that because
that's sex selection abortion and by the
letter of the law you can't just have an
abortion for any reason it has to be to
continue with this pregnancy is gonna
you know impact the life impact the
health the mental health the physical
child would have been birthed on loved
but yeah but that's not the law I'm just
telling you what the law is yeah but out
of interest that like like again like
this you can dive in into the mental
health point be great right now because
yeah but she but he's okay do I have a
question do you think a kid is less
valuable because they don't have parents
no
do I think a child is less valuable
that's what it sounds like when you're
saying if and I'm I might have misheard
you but
um if a kid is born and they don't have
loving parents um that they're somehow
less valuable and they shouldn't be
alive no I definitely not I don't agree
with that like no child is over any less
no no you know human is of any less
value regarding what anyone else thinks
of them but until it's here at what
point are we protecting the human right
of the person that is well that's going
through the chain that's the question I
had for you I think that's where it
started okay well maybe I misunderstood
no it's like at what point is a life of
life
so like when does fundamentals because I
think we protect the the mother's life
no so I guess that's why I'm saying like
I think there's Parts where we would all
agree like everyone in this room would
say the day before like a week before
you give birth
no that's that's too far right there's
no one that disagrees so my question is
at what point does a life become a life
so when when should abortion be legal if
you got to pick the laws tomorrow
and that's why I showed you the the
pamphlet so you could see the stages of
development so like at what point yeah
like my back question to that was and I
think we've gone around in a giant Loop
was what scientifically decided that
point so that I can have some
information to face an opinion on
because I don't know I don't understand
why 20s why 26 weeks who decided that
and why so it's not really hard for me
to put an opinion on something like I
don't know normally because it was
politicians I mean I think I mean but
what was that like you were in the U.S
oh so I'm from the US
um but women sway elections so a lot of
times if like if they if people running
can say
um
they can run on abortion rights they can
get when women are 55 of the population
and they overwhelmingly in the U.S um 68
vote Democrat and so that's how they win
elections is by saying oh you get more
abortion rates more abortion rights and
so that that's what I would guess but I
don't know but not even a voting issue
in this nation at all yeah I still don't
know what up like
your question to me is I still find it
hard to answer because I still don't
know from that response as to like why
22 weeks was decided by science
I think it was viability so when when if
the if the child can survive outside of
the mother's womb okay so as we said
around and that used to be 28 weeks I
believe
on its own without a mother basically
yeah and as as technology develops
obviously that's happening earlier and
earlier yeah and again like before they
couldn't really see when they didn't
have scans as well that it used to be
higher but they lowered it when we
started to see the child by the time
you're 24 weeks pregnant the baby has a
chance of survival if they're born most
babies born before this time cannot live
because their lungs and other vital
organs are not fully developed enough
um but I think in the UK you said it's
26 weeks or 24. 24. and I want to say
the earliest pregnancy that survived is
like 21 or 22 it's like two weeks before
whenever it's legal here okay so by
still based on that information
when a baby can survive on his own
without affecting anyone else's human
rights
then it's life
until that point you're you're choosing
a life over a life would you would you
agree it's too late here since there's
been babies that have survived before
what age is it here
and a baby no it's it's more legal here
like in the US it depends on the state
but um and a baby has survived at 22
weeks how many babies it's rare it's not
what was the circumstances that that
baby was born and do we actually know
the exact perceptions I'm sure I'm sure
I'm not sure they had a lot of medical
care I'm sure that's not common
um but then it kind of goes back to like
are people more valuable that have
access to Medical Care
so it you know but so I was just I need
time to find I need to put time to
process that question because that's
like a whole nother unpacking yeah you
know like
everyone I believe should have access to
like government-funded Medical Care
everyone in all countries I don't
believe that anyone should be
prioritized or negligized based on their
anything at all apart from where they oh
situation because you wouldn't give that
same right to a child in the womb say
that again sorry
um I'm saying apart from you said anyone
but you're so in that you're assuming
that the child in the womb is not a
person I'm not assuming that I
acknowledge that is a human that it is
growing but it is it's one right it's
one human right or another right you're
you're saying that the mother's human
rights have to be sacrificed for that of
something else that is actually not its
own isn't that isn't that motherhood
it's like putting your kids before you
it's unconditional love yeah
so we sacrifice the child
are we sacrificing the child or we
sacrificing the mother would you prefer
to sacrifice the mother over the child
and no one's I don't think anyone here
is advocating for killing the mother no
so then where's the sacrifice on that
side of it
I I agree with pearl where mothers have
to make sacrifice all the time no I'm
not arguing that the mother should pass
I'm just saying like I think I thought I
heard you say mental health yeah too
yeah and I I just feel like so um that
little Baxter I'm one of um 10 kids oh
um and my um my parents got my mom got
pregnant when she was 17. wow um and all
by the same father of interest
um so we adopted three
um so we took in three kids and they um
biologically seven but one brother I
didn't find out about until I was 22.
wow because that my mom um they were so
young that they gave that kid up for
adoption
and then they re and I didn't know he
existed until I was 22. wow so I was
kind of like what if I yeah last week
but it's kind of like
um so I just like look at my mom and I'm
just like
you know it wasn't about her like it was
about her kid first and like I don't
know
like you you would agree that um
a woman should sacrifice her human
rights that include mental health if we
if we include in mental health under the
human body I don't think that you should
um for kill I'm not saying like kill the
mother but I if mental health yeah you
are killing a part of her that's why
people choose it right
you are killing a part of a woman
when
you're taking away the twist for her I
think children I I don't I mean I think
you women like you kill a part of a
woman when you get an abortion I mean
listen to their stories yeah so so it's
but do I think I mean I can't tell
people what to do and how to live it's
legal so that's poor choice but no no
I'm saying like I don't have any say in
it how it is now but I'm saying mental
health yeah stick it out give the kid up
for adoption my mom came back from it
she she had 10 kids and the story they
started a multi-million dollar business
and they're broke broke dead broke they
found a great family my brother just got
married they just he just had his first
kid how is your brother like like he's
great he's phenomenal he's like actually
have a good like does he have like
himself and he yeah is that because he
had money no my parents were not like
they um they were poor so they had
um like they they didn't grow up with
money my dad was one of 13. my mom was
one and I were catholic we don't really
believe in birth control
I have a bit on the pill but
um not really no um I just
careful I don't know
um but
yeah I mean I just see my mom and she
just put it was always like family
this is why I said okay it was always
family like before
um first and so even though it was
really it was super embarrassing for her
she was 17. she was like the the family
like everyone kind of like no one else
had done that in the family you know and
it was really embarrassing but like she
always knew that it was about like it
wasn't about her it was bigger than her
and now that I see like what Greg turned
out to be I just think it would be
this
okay this is why
um I just think it would be like a shame
um if she'd aborted him because like he
you know he grew up he just had his
first kid he just got married to a grave
adoption like that's like aligned with
like uh if if someone has chosen that
they don't want to continue through to
like full-time pregnancy and you would
agree that it would be okay to put them
up for adoption so therefore give give
them away but still allow them yeah and
do you know how many families like it I
think it's gonna
there are going to be with women like
the age of first marriage average age of
first marriage is 31 in the UK 90 of
your eggs are gone by 30. they're going
to be a lot
a lot of women that want to adopt
there's a lot of kids too I thought all
right yeah and like a lot of times like
the argument I hear is oh pro-life
people don't do anything with adoption
but every like the most pro-life people
I know have been involved in adoption
like my parents adopted three kids and
it's always it's always the pro-choice
people that never adopt it do you think
that like the uh Narrative of adoption
this is like completely neutral stance
has been like force-fed by the
government like
depopularize
um what do you mean
um
like lower the population basically yeah
do you think there's other uh beings
that force that are feeding the
narrative and funding the there's just
too much [ __ ] that like lines up like I
don't know in the in the US it's
actually it's actually really creepy
um because as I was saying earlier
um I mean birth control was developed in
the 1960s then they then they develop
abortion
um I don't know if adoption like goes
into that because I'd imagine if people
want a population control they would
encourage abortion over to option
um but
now in the US it's actually really like
Margaret Sanger was a eugenicist and
that's the number one provider of
Planned Parenthood and her her goal was
to exterminate the black population and
she's doing it the black population
would be double today in the U.S and 80
of planned parenthoods are located
located in a minority neighborhood and
when you think about it like if a normal
company that was how they were founded
people would be up in arms but nobody
cares and it's like a genocide that's
happening in front of our eyes and they
they might like they would have
marketing plans that talked about like
this is how we Market it to low-income
women this is how we Market it says like
you know they they denounce it but it's
like if you say oh we're not doing it
but you're still doing the same thing
it's like I
but you know no one cares
and because it's like a woman's right to
choose and it's interesting because I
don't know if you've looked at like the
marketing language that they talk about
where it's like they
instead of calling it a baby they'll
call it a fetus and they do that like
language is important and they do that
so people aren't as aware of what
they're doing and it's kind of like you
know when she said she had her abortion
and it came out and it was a full a full
child she had no idea do you think that
like the uh abortion
companies or services and stuff
appropriate word there and intentionally
hide the visual graphic side of it for
that or do you think they've heard
someone come to them and say I don't
want this this is my choice and then
they are protecting their mental health
which is what they've come to say that
they can't have it for
um 100 I think too many people which way
does that go I just I just think it's a
business and I just think they're trying
to make and and there is a girl that
quit Planned Parenthood that came out
and talked about this how um what they
do is they put you on birth control that
doesn't really work so how many girls
take the pill at the same time every day
and they try to push those and then what
they'll do is they'll um then push
abortion and they're supposed to push
like a like say this is your option for
adoption this is this this is that but
they don't really do that they just push
abortion and then they get paid yes
that's what she said in the UK in the US
and why like they they say oh we have
all these different services but why are
the Planned Parenthood Clinic clinics
shutting down in the U.S if that's true
when Roe versus Wade was passed if it's
just one of many services I think that
you say the same thing
I don't um the UK know they're
government funded so there you go to NHS
90 I think it says so there's no
business driven decision here in the
same way but still there's people who
have got those
um kind of contracts so Mary soaps and
b-pass have uh abortion industries that
are have got those contracts and they
have like we could like do all the
profits of their company and actually
see whether they are profiting from the
decisions based and therefore give like
an in an intention as to why they would
hide the graphics and visuals behind it
I know obviously the experience that you
guys I think I think about okay think of
it imagine you're you're selling
something and your goal is to make money
yeah I don't I don't necessarily think
that every person that works at Planned
Parenthood is thinking about Eugenics
right I don't necessarily but I do think
people in general want to make money so
if you were going to start a Planned
Parenthood and you put it in you put it
somewhere right and you found out that
you lose 50 of your customer base let's
I'm just doing a number I don't what
they actually are but let's say you lose
50 percent of your customer base and you
get paid let's say a thousand dollars
per abortion so if there's 20 customers
that come in you could get twenty
thousand dollars
um and let's say so you can make twenty
thousand dollars without showing them
anything
or you can make ten thousand dollars and
show them stuff what are you what are
you gonna do yeah is my guess but I
don't I don't actually know and in the
UK and in the UK well the UK is so
privately fun so in the U.S sorry in the
in the UK like you have to understand
there's still government contracts so
like right now I have a private business
like I I own the studio this is like
just me but let's say I wanted to be get
fun I'm looking when I go to the us
about getting seeing if like different
cities could give us funding potentially
and you still have to like bid for a
contract so if you want to
go I don't know into sell missiles to
the government like you still have to
bid
and like there's still money and you see
what I'm saying it's just someone
somewhere in the UK that is making money
of not showing people the graphics and
visual sides of abortions as is my get
I'm not I don't know this I'm just
that's that's what I would guess is
they're in it for money
the question is really why are they not
showing those those I guess because more
people would say no yeah my yeah I might
guess my my assumption of it is
obviously there's that side of it but
also like if you've gone there and you
said like
I don't want to keep this baby based on
my mental health from a psychologist's
stance would it be good for your mental
health to then show you an extremely
graphic image or procedure when you've
already decided that you don't want that
yeah like at what point does it become
protection of your mental health which
is the reason why you went in the first
place 100 because if your mental health
is bad now and then you you have an
abortion and see what the hell is going
on here it's going to get way worse than
it already was yeah yeah 100 like
imagine if it before imagine if if your
mental health was bad like you're
depressed and anxious everything and
then they they for example you don't get
shown the video right and then you have
the abortion and then you you become
more depressed because like if you if
they actually just gave you that warning
sign like okay look here's what it looks
like here's what it's going to be here's
what it might happen it you know you
kind of would consider it like oh I
think my mental health would get way
worse and I feel like let me just try
and give it a go you know I think it's
you to believe that intention isn't to
protect your mental health on any level
and that's why they've not decided to
show you the pictures despite all three
counseling do you think intention
matters
if the outcome is is if the out does
intention matter if the outcome is women
not being informed about a medical
procedure I think that it's important to
be objective and understand as to why
that decision was made like subjectively
obviously
being explained magical procedures may
be a good implementation in that process
would be to be given the choice do you
want to see this do you know I don't
know if that is an option or not whether
you actually are given that choice no
it's not but I feel like if we because
obviously if I've come to a doctor and
said like I'm experiencing XYZ and I'm
suffering and I can't do this and I
don't want this
mental health tick they're not gonna
then just like oh and by the way here's
a slideshow that I prepared earlier of
extremely graphic images that you're
about to decide that you'll want to go
through yeah but they should tell you
what's going on yeah but do they not
even do they not explain to you that
you're you're gonna have the baby
removed from your body is it they didn't
even understand conditions that you must
surely you have to sign somewhere let
her yeah go ahead and eat they don't
even show you like what it can look like
like say like the stages of the baby
they don't even show you that they don't
find anything they just say the tissues
will come out the tissues they don't
even say a baby or a body or anything
just tissues cells what are they say do
you sign it off like is it like oh
that's just mad I can't remember if I
was quite long ago um yeah because that
like surely if you signed it like what
are you actually signing like did you
read it you know like is there a lateral
like uh comprehension understanding work
this is part of the informing process
though because like I mentioned before
and as I feel like everybody would agree
on this panel if you're going in for a
procedure in the hospital everything is
explained to you you are walk through
whatever procedure you're going to have
with that consultant before you get to
the
endpoint where you are signing off
because I do remember I did sign a piece
now am I signing that piece of paper
based on being informed properly or am I
signing that piece of paper based on
the other elements that are taking place
and the other
circumstances that has brought me to
that point does that make sense yeah
um so
no doctors are not carefully
um considering
what this woman is going through because
if you did you would then walk her
through that process yeah why are you
why is it such a rest decision to get
her to sign that piece of paper or to
agree to having that abortion
I don't see the duty of care in that um
are we displayed like is it like a given
in all um so like across the board of
all medical procedures in the UK are we
always given pictures and videos of the
procedure that we're about to go under
no but we can at least Google it that's
why so we cannot Google abortions no
it's very hard it's very hard
because we have the pamphlet right there
that displays that's no that's why like
in all honesty that's why I invited her
on because we just made it no because no
because because I I tried to do a
similar like show a couple months ago
and I just thought it was crazy that I
couldn't find videos and pictures at
each stage of the development that was
like clear and actual pictures and
videos of the I I couldn't find it for
the life of me I'm not saying it's not
there but you don't think it's strange
that a procedure that's so common like
the information should be at the top of
Google but it's not and and my mind goes
to why who protects Google's images
like who hides it in Google Matrix The
Matrix The Matrix if you know yeah
probably Google probably even on this
show they'll be there now started doing
an abortion since Roe v Wade was
overturned they've now started doing an
abortion warning just like they did with
covid and vaccination you know if anyone
said anything they they put a you know
this is a link to the NHS so they're
doing the same with abortion
um just that that warning to say that
it's just to try and
get that there's only one kind of
narrative in the NHS and also they don't
really give you like they they need they
kind of like make you rush into it as
well they're kind of like okay so have
you decided okay so you have this Choice
what is it going to be you know it's
like okay like let me think about it you
know and they like when I was quite
Young when I had it done so I was a
child really so how can a child decide
on a child's life if that makes sense
like it it kind of has to have some sort
of age limit as well I think like I
don't know especially an age limit on
sex then at the same point in time like
do you think the two should go hand in
hand yeah 100 yeah
yeah
I mean yeah I think we'd agree like tan
too young yeah like at some point there
is a limit I mean I guess
you can't stop them but your parents
should be involved definitely I think
parents are big part to play in this
because just going back to what you're
saying
um like if my daughter was to have a
procedure again I have to keep using
this in line I will definitely have a
part to play in making sure that that
procedure procedure that she's having
I'm happy with it because by law she's
not
yeah do you know what I mean but by law
I know she knows now my mom already
knows yeah
um and that was part of my healing
process because I just thought why
should I have to hide that like that was
a big part of me do you know what I mean
and I at the point at that time I feel
like I was so I felt like I was so alone
felt like I had to keep it a secret
why do you know what I mean that was
just Society it was it changed my life
significantly and I feel like I should
have had the support even if I was to
have gone through with it
would you
um
have an abortion now like if I was to
have one that could be yeah sure
that's a good question yeah no I
wouldn't obviously because of the
experiences that I've had obviously I've
taken precautions now I'm so like really
um different about it but yeah no I
wouldn't because how old are you 25 25.
do you um if you could like never had
another child would that make you think
differently about the abortions I I
could never think like that because it
would do I would I would be depressed
and and if I was to think about the
moments that I've experienced in during
abortions for example like it's
depressing like I would be depressed I
would be like you know I'm unhappy I
just wonder if as many women would abort
their children if like they knew that
they wouldn't have another like if that
was their only child do you think like
women would move the same way that
actually crosses your mind as well when
you are pregnant like you actually think
oh what if you know but
yeah I mean you can't change it you're
right there's no point in like exactly
but I was just curious did you have
children later ah five oh you have five
kids oh that's so nice yeah I have my
first daughter is actually my step
towards her
um
sorry I'm married obviously as I stated
in the beginning and then my husband and
I have
all together
um well I think we're gonna wrap up the
show it's almost midnight thank you guys
yeah I feel like no it goes by fast
doesn't it um I'm gonna Read Super chats
guys after they do final thoughts um and
you guys can put any social media I
really appreciate how calm this is but I
swear to everyone's always screaming
during this one and this is yeah
um so starting there and then go around
a final thoughts and on any social media
you want to plug yeah I just think that
people need to know the reality they
need to know the humanity of the child
in the womb and the reality of abortion
and
um yeah people can go to follow us or
CBR UK at CBR underscore UK and we'll go
to our website
cbruk.org and there's
um yeah loads of information on the the
development of the child and there's
lots of links for support for women
who've been through abortion as well I'd
want to say to anyone who's experienced
abortion that there is There's Hope and
there is healing
um so yeah
yeah
um final thought for me is I think
everybody's always going to have an
opinion on it
um but for me and I think my opinion
will always be
um you know the woman's body is women's
Choice
um
so yeah and my Instagram is at Macy dot
underscore underscore that's m a c e y
my final thought on it is
um
yeah
that women should be better informed
um and
I just want everyone out there to know
that if you have been through an
abortion that there is
two School of thoughts you you can
either be impacted by it or shut it down
um in your mental
box but
um I'm
I know that there is hope there is
healing and I do have a social media
platform called voice for the voiceless
UK
um and we advocate for
women that have been through the trauma
of abortion and just one last call of
thought well one last thing as well is
abortion doesn't just impact the woman
it impacts the child as well so we need
to think about the two
oh so you're going out for noodles
I am I'm grateful for the things I've
learned today there isn't a change in my
belief currently that um we should have
that choice taken out of our hands and
that that human rights should be given
to something that is still dependent on
us to be alive I do think that
um understanding why it's so heavily
sensed on Google and why the information
in the images so um I'm going to say
protected
needs to be unpacked and that it should
be as easy to Google as a knee surgery I
was going to ask if you would agree that
it should be yeah like women should be
better informed about this 100 I think I
think that's one thing that I feel like
pro-choice and pro-life people could
come together on yeah a woman should be
better in foreign if you're making a
choice I think you should have all of
the information in front of you and I
think like obviously we use Google like
it's Bible now so like being able to
Google it should be possible and
understanding who from Google is
preventing that is really important and
I still think that then it needs to be
fully understood as to why it's not
shown in the uh consultation that you do
have when you go and like you're signing
off on these things and like and
navigating whether that's to protect the
mental health if that's why you're
saying they're there or whether there's
other uh financial and motivations
behind the decision to um
hide
the information and the graphic side of
the procedure and also to um
yeah to like uh
obviously it's a time restriction by
nature but yeah to to make sure that the
person has like more and the person has
the maximum amount of information
required to make a choice themselves for
sure I can definitely meet you guys in
the middle there for sure
yeah
um I think this is more of a female
topic when it comes to abortion so I
think I played my part for the men
um I just said it should be 50 50. so
that's all I can say
um any last final thoughts I'd probably
say
rest in peace to The Godfather Kevin
Samuels
um shout out to fresh and fit my guy
Myron my guy fresh love them respect to
Paul she's been doing it for the guys
um and make sure men your pullout game
is strong because that's what you can
rely on and Hope on
um condoms no no pull out game and also
um what else yeah yeah I'm not I'm not
co-siding that one and um yeah it's his
final thought I'll let him yeah and as
pay as Paul said um for the women you
can't really check out
um on Google YouTube about abortion so
the best thing to do is just speak to
someone who's been through it experience
look at her website check out obviously
um her website Ruth's website and um
yeah just try your best to get out of
the Matrix what was the website called
again CBR
uk.org so c b r u k dot org okay cool
and they can or they can go easier to
remember
abortionreality.com go to
abortionreality.com and that'll link you
too and will they see like can you
actually see a procedure of an abortion
oh wow okay
um I can't do reactions to those don't
get me off YouTube god
um my final thought is probably
just men should just be careful as well
you know like as you can see it does
sort of affect the women as well at the
same time
um so sex is just more than than sex if
that makes sense and and for women to be
careful and also take accountability as
well because
you know just because you think oh okay
it can be deleted and and whatnot it's
not you know it should be it should be
thought a bit better than that
um however you know I still think you
know as murder
um however I still think we're born with
a free will therefore I still feel like
it's a free choice
um but yeah that's it socials
um yeah I'm a mental health therapist
guys so if you need any mental help I'm
here k-e-s-j-a underscore H C S
thank you I don't know what you're
mouthing to me my social I think oh yeah
go ahead go ahead uh yeah so um you can
catch me on social media extreme to the
T that's extreme without the e
so um I do appreciate you two being very
open about your experiences
um I know that's not easy to like talk
about publicly so I do appreciate you
guys
um both being really candid about that
um okay guys
um I'm gonna read some super chats
before we end the show um anything that
you guys put I'm going to read so T Kane
a man who aborts responsibility of his
baby is a deadbeat rightfully so a woman
who aborts responsibility of her baby is
also a deadbeat um C Dumbledore this is
an amazing display of How Deeply she has
been indoctrinated to believe things
that are objectively false and
self-destructive
yet she goes to such lengths to defend
her own destruction
um December zero eight one government
Health Care isn't free they promote
abortion to lighten the load of the
power the poor people on the health
system not the women for the women but
the government
seeking God finding Jesus the government
split um parents and led mothers away
from their children with jobs and now
their child is shaped by the state and
nobody protects them Das token um
um closing of legs is 99.9 effective if
she'll kill the baby she'll kill the
marriage I missed the era of when women
actually loved babies
um death token if she'll abort her own
baby in her on her own will imagine the
Havoc Havoc she'll wreak on a
relationship
um Lou casley ex-abortionist Dr Bernard
nathanalist noted how the abortion
industry purposely fabricated the number
of illegal abortions prior to Roe versus
Wade C Dumbledore 68 of women vote
liberal 54 percent of married but
married women vote conservative since
the mid-2000s the entire strategy has
been to keep women single and scared in
order to control their vote it's math
well I mean the fans know what I think
about that
um based ape do you think that people
are ethically obligated to reproduce
given that not doing so is an act of
participation in the destruction of the
world you inherited that you have
obligations outside of self-interest
Edgar in El Salvador super legal
recently in Colombia Colombia they
legalized it on moblets Wow Pearl thank
you for showing us the desensitive how
desensitized our generation is God help
us all on the AL Factor if you look at
the pamphlet and decide
if you have to look at the pamphlet to
decide to cut up cut off point you don't
know enough about the sub subject to be
making that decision
see Dumbledore if they'll defend with
every breath their ability ability to
prevent someone else's first breath in
order to not be held accountable for
their feelings and emotions hyper
hypergamy NSX firstly great panel
secondly pro-choice equals your sole
responsibility support comes when you
ask pro life equals no choice so
community and support is offered without
asking Rey I know that this will be
demonetized and throttled but thank you
for the honest conversation I'm going to
refresh just to make sure there aren't
any more guys like the video that's the
most important metric that YouTube uses
to push out these videos oh Auntie Jenny
I enjoyed this conversation even the
deflector
um okay so let me
guys a couple announcements before we
end the show the first is that we have
two clips channels the first is just
pearly clips and the second is Pearl
daily go to subscribe to both also guys
join our memberships if you want to be a
part of the chat it's only five dollars
which is the price of a cup of coffee a
month
um also um ten dollar tier you get to
see me freestyling and also you get to
be a part of our Discord to sign up for
that
um and you get to see our behind the
scenes Vlogs we have fun here
um and you can see like you know
different videos that we do behind the
scenes
um tier three connect with me on social
media this means having access to my
inbox fourth tier you get a one-on-one
call with me once a month if you want to
put on a live show that's what I
recommend because
um there's a lot that goes into it and I
have a lot of insights go follow my
Instagram just probably things one
follow my tick tocks justperly things
dot five and just pearly things six
thank you for 750k Subs
um like the video on your way out
subscribe to wife school that video
blessing you know when we're dropping
wife School episode one
no okay well we as are we gonna do
another edit of it
are we keeping it okay week week one to
two weeks we have it we have it filmed
it's just I don't know we're editing it
anyways like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and we'll talk
to you next time